[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Linc and I'm
Rhett this week is time for another
conversation with someone interesting
from the internet and this week that
person that's gonna be sitting right
here at the round table of dim lighting
is Vitaly this is Dora that's key one of
the most popular prank video producers
on the youtubes now as you probably know
prank videos are huge I mean they're not
video game videos on YouTube but they're
I mean close second a probably a close
second so I mean we there was a big
fascination factor on our part and
Vitaly was you know is one of the
biggest guys and in this genre so very
excited to talk to him what did we
discuss we discussed the details behind
a couple of his most extreme pranks the
Miami zombie attack and the one that got
him arrested and jailed for 45 days and
unexpectedly we got into a controversial
story that actually just surfaced at the
end of 2013 and that was it was
discovered that he was he made an
appearance in a porn video and people
found this out now in doing our research
in preparing for this conversation we
found this out we thought he'd already
kind of addressed it publicly and we
didn't know how relevant it was to his
whole prank career and YouTube and that
kind of thing but he had a quote he had
a quote in an article and like he may
have tweeted a couple of things he
certainly hadn't gone into detail but
really just didn't think we were gonna
go there but as you'll hear we're asking
her about the first videos he made and I
think he thought we were trying to get
it out of him he misinterpreted us that
we were trying to get it out of him but
you know ultimately he was honest about
it we had the discussion I think it gave
him the grounds to be more more honest
and to go a little bit further about it
and then he has to date so you can
expect that and I also take that as a
warning if if you don't want to hear
things discussed about the porn industry
okay to uh you know to check out now but
we also discussed the you know
him growing up and culture shock of
immigrating from the Ukraine and middle
school and lots of inner workings about
a guy who creates the most shocking
over-the-top pranks on the internet
about living and of course you know we
start talking to a guy who's done prank
videos or is doing prank videos that's
this thing it makes us think about some
of the prank videos that we've done
including one of our first videos we
mentioned this to him as well um it's
it's one of the first videos we ever
posted well it was a video that existed
before we actually had a YouTube channel
so when we got our YouTube channel there
were a series of videos that we just
uploaded initially right when we started
in 2006 on July 24 2006 one of those
videos is called cutting strangers nose
hairs at the mall and when we went you
know we mentioned it in our conversation
with Vitaly and then when we go back I
felt sure that we had made this video
private because it's so embarrassing
there are many embarrassing points so
you can watch this thing it's on our
main channel cutting strangers nose
hairs at the mall and that's what we did
I mean four and a half minutes it takes
about two and a half minutes to get into
it but it's it's it's so embarrassing
because it's such an old video but it's
um a that was one of the things we were
trying to do way back then was kind of
do the prank thing I remember going to
the mall and going to Sears and buying
that nose hair trimmer and saying let's
just see if we can put it up people's
noses and then you also bought right
next to it they were selling a keyboard
thank you cleaner right it sucks dust
out of vacuum so then I would I said
okay I'll cut their nose hairs and then
you can suck it out if any no one will
let us do this but let's see what you
know we dressed up in suits or at least
Blazers in khakis and try to look
official and we said okay let's go up to
people and we're gonna just try to
actually demonstrate our hair hair
removal system which consisted of link
cutting the nose hairs and me vacuuming
out of people's actual noses now you can
watch the video to see for yourself it's
it's I mean you know what you don't even
have to I'm not because this is not
kind of video that I'm going to
recommend watching for entertainment
other than just the fact that we're
referencing it and it's a part of our
past and it is pertinent to this
conversation that's the only reason that
I'm gonna suggest that you watch it
because it's a bad video that's why it's
got 26,000 views as opposed to 26
million views like the guy we're talking
to today but mm-hmm
not only and I our pants were really big
not only am i embarrassed brother
haircut that I had the chin strap that I
was supporting the pants we look like
clowns like literally well it's for well
because at that time that was the
fashion there were two things that were
kind of in and we well first of all we
shot the video in like oh five maybe oh
four potentially and so at the time
baggy pants were the thing that we were
wearing especially for prank videos and
did you did you notice we look like
clowns not only because of the baggy
pants but because of the shoes they had
like they're like dress shoes with
really a Souls big really big shoes like
clown shoes we the bottom half of our
bodies look like clowns
and funnier Tom have one far behind but
there was this element that I think our
accents are very versus other there's
something that we get into with Vitaly
and that is this thing you have to psych
yourself up you have to go into the zone
get into a zone in order to approach
people and ask them to do something that
makes them feel uncomfortable because
that's we establish in our conversation
with with him I do not like making
people people feel like comfortable you
actually like my perception is you enjoy
making people feel uncomfortable because
a big part of your humor a lot of times
when you're like in a group or like at a
party or something like is I'm gonna say
something and it's gonna make but this
person or everyone feel uncomfortable
mm-hmm and do you like it like it is are
you what what it what is your goal
because it seems like you're like okay I
did what I was trying to do and now
everybody feels uncomfortable and I and
I shudder that I can't stand I can't
stand it I think now that I've succeeded
at getting a
of attention and but like actually being
an entertainer I don't have as much of
that itch as I had like way back then -
totally sacrifice my you know my own
pride of being of looking like an idiot
to make some in the to make someone else
to like an idiot and get a laugh but I
don't even think I don't think it's
taking advantage of people I don't I
wouldn't you may have done that a little
bit in high school I'm not talking about
making fun of somebody right I talk
about it's doing something much I would
be very nervous I would not want to or
would never get excited about trimming
someone's nose hairs are doing anything
close to what Vitaly does today but I
still have this I still have a little
bit of it like at a party in a group
when I'll be like okay this is not gonna
be funny to anybody but me but for some
reason I'm gonna say it anyway
because I don't maybe some will happen
and it just made if it makes people feel
weird it's not I'm not doing it to make
them feel weird because I don't think
that's funny
I don't know exactly why I do it I think
it's just sometimes it's just like you
did you see a therapist this isn't funny
that will also be funny to me that's an
interesting comedic strategy if this is
not funny
well that'll be funny to me so it's like
a win-win there's no I can't lose and
people may feel a little weird but it'll
be funny to me I think one of the things
that makes people feel that makes people
want to watch these videos that Vitaly
does is there is a I would never do that
I could never do that quality to them
and to see somebody actually do it to
have the balls to actually make some of
these things happen and then to get the
authentic reactions from people people
are kind of addicted to that process and
I know that it makes me feel
uncomfortable when I watch them but that
also but it also makes you want to keep
seeing the reactions you know the key to
it because whenever we conceptualize a
video and we don't do this very often
where it's going to involve us trying to
get this reaction out of somebody
our most recent one being the the
invisible
dog right I just get anxious about it
I'm anxious about it
four days until we actually do it and
then what as soon as we do I'm glad we
got done with that video I mean I could
never have a prank channel I mean I
wouldn't no I would never I would
wouldn't sleep I but I couldn't either
you're saying you couldn't I could not
now I might could have way back in the
day when I really I wasn't having the
attention so now that I have it I have
it I can do it in ways I'm much more
comfortable getting it well in one sense
it's unfortunate that we are not willing
to do a prank channel because apparently
you can a mess over five million
subscribers doing it and get close to
half a billion that's a billion with a B
views this is really working for it in
less than three years that's what Vitaly
has done his pranks have been featured
on tosh point-o and all other types of
TV outlets because you know they're
hungry for this type of stuff he's
collaborated with some of the most
esteemed pranksters including jackasses
steve-o and now he has sat down and been
ear biscuit it yeah yes pin so here you
go here it is banana chips no but it's
funny that you said because I was
actually get a banana and eat it in the
middle of podcast butter that was gonna
be rude now that wouldn't be rooted I
would hear that people always say they
love natural mouth sounds on this on
this show the more that you can make
them work the better he's being
facetious
I'm actually pretty self-conscious of my
mouth sounds like on our show that would
shoot over there good mythical morning
we eat a lot of stuff and when I watch
it back I just I hear my mouth sounds
and they Clara felt like I should
apologize out you are you do you think
you're a loud chewer normal chew or
silent Scheuer I'm allowed no I'm a
silent sure when it's with my friends
but when it's with girls I'm doing loud
to get their attention
oh you think the girls like a loud
chewer yep it's like well if that guy
can if I can hear him eat food that must
mean he's a caring person I'm trying to
trust some sight I don't know maybe like
eat like an animal maybe not chew Oh
already going down yeah I want to
attract this there was actually a woman
that was actually a funny story about
that you want to hear it yeah of course
I saw it this is best restaurant next to
my house Jack and Jill I took him for
the first time John my manager but um so
I went there and I ordered half a
chicken right I'm eating this half a
chicken outside and there's a glass to
go you know just you can see inside
right so there's two hot girls just
eating on like ah please don't watch me
I'm like every time I look they don't
see me and I just keep eating dead
chicken like nasty I'm like killing it
right mm-hmm
so then my friend walks in into Jack and
Jill and he knows those girls so he
starts talking to them and then he
weighs me over and then I'm like okay
what now and I thought the girls mind
their own business they actually were
watching me the whole time eating that
chicken they're like wow we loved the
way you were eating them you respond to
that
I got her number she said I still didn't
get her but we loved the way you eat the
chicken we love the way said that yep
yep I was well actually worrying for her
not to see me like I was taking a bite
I'm looking over
nobody's looking like thanks God and
then they said they were part of the
whole thing what part of town we talking
about everybody else oh okay yeah around
there gold digger and these women were
like in their late fifties er no they
were actually pretty young 20 well
that's what everyone that's what the
late fifties women look like in I'm
gonna check the ID now I want to talk
about the the getting the the number
Frank which you kind of mentioned here
but I want to wait to get to that I sure
I I just can't wait to get right to the
zombie prank okay that's the one that's
old already forgot about that right off
the bat I mean I just I have to go back
and talk about that one cuz that's
that's the one that basically blew up
for you that they that was the the first
huge one right I think if that video
didn't happened I wouldn't be sitting
here Anna so what's the backstory on
that one what's the backstory I was
doing videos YouTube videos and I had
like 10,000 subscribers at a time and
then I went out to do the zombie prank
and now this is right after like the
yeah yeah if you want the bath salt
story the homeless person ate another
homeless person's face so everybody's
tweeting zombies are coming in Miami in
Miami bass holes but a lot of spreading
and yeah yeah I live I used to live in
Boca which is 40 minutes from Miami okay
so I just like there's this fear going
around of people there's this fear of
bath salts great zombie zai mattis's
twitter status is all about the zombies
in Miami were scared and it happened
like two days after I dressed up as a
zombie and I had no problem scaring
people I think I was like the king I
could clear the holes this is two days
after the news story breaks yeah yeah I
got a I got a jump on this yes so you
you weren't making prank videos before
that I was I was okay you were yeah was
but they weren't getting hits they're
like a couple thousand views okay yep so
you go out and you know I well at first
I started sergeant Tyrell but first I
started actually screaming out of the
car like driving by people and having
blood on my face and like popping out
and by driving you know driving through
yeah yeah in the car yeah pretty much
dry drive through zombie break right
kinda yeah but not actually the drive
thru drive through and how are people
responding yeah no reactions I'm like
what am i doing why don't I actually
just put rip clothing and actually go
out there so go home and I found a tie i
put her over my head because i thought
it looked cool there's a nice touch yes
yeah favorite part and then no shoes
bare feet dress bands dress shirt and i
went out and put blood all over it and
it worked every time i went to if barely
any behind the scenes on it there is
meaning most of what happened made its
way into the video it wasn't like yeah
shoot all day no no it was like two two
days I shot it two days three hours each
day six hours yeah it was easy you just
come out of the car and they just run
yeah bingo and you just kind of chased
them with a limp pretty much and then
and the noises yes noises the growling
and then I tried to him it's a prank but
they just kept running well it some of
the reactions there was kind of a
discovery to it that you tried it one
way it didn't okay I'm in the car this
isn't working
why don't
get out and then that started to work
yes what I mean when you're I guess for
that that prank in particular were you
scared of okay I think the thing that
rhett and I said were he could be
shocked you know I mean I didn't think
about that when I do my videos I just
get into character I kind of forgot that
gods even exist at that point and I'm
being serious like I just I was just in
my zone I was like this is so much fun
so you're even thinking getting shot and
stuff like that I mean we're never in in
the way distant past we would kind of
flirt with kind of prank videos or just
man on the street type of videos I know
in my mind it would be one of the first
videos we may was trimming strangers
nose hairs oh yeah we had a nose hair
trimmer this is like 2006 it might have
been 2005 this is before you too long
ago so it's not on YouTube it is gonna
take the idea and say it was original it
wasn't great you're gonna do it's
nowhere near you know the caliber of
what you're pulling off but I remember
very quickly being able to just get over
this fear because because I was thinking
about an audience yes so you don't have
as much of that the switch that just
turns off and I'm just gonna trim
people's nose hairs or I'm just gonna
yeah I have there's a lot for me to
personally overcome when I'm I don't
like making people feel uncomfortable in
real life so when I try to when we do a
video where that's the point we don't do
a lot that are like that I there's like
this I gotta like psych myself up like
it's going back to my basketball days
where I have to I'm in the locker room
right before the game and I've got to
psych myself into you know I got pumped
myself yeah yeah absolutely
do you have the same approach my
approach is hilarious
I have to walk around 45 minutes before
hit do anybody and I went through your
mind so you just like I'm just yeah I'm
just thinking like my camera guy gets
pissed at me cuz he just follows me I'm
just like I'm about to go I'm about to
go and he's pushing me I was
acknowledged out to go and I'm like this
way back that way this way yet back and
forth and I was like alright I'm ready
I said do one it's it's on so it's
running like jumping off a cliff like
into a body of water
yeah if you say so you've never tried
that mm-hmm well it is like that I
wouldn't be much of a prank though I
mean I do lots of pacing before I jump
off cliffs in the bodies of water yeah
at least back in my high school days at
the reservoir but you're saying once you
get going I mean you you pace you're
nervous and then what you get going it
you're in character and yeah you don't
have to yeah you're you're another
person at that point you are the person
you are the zombie with a pretty much
but desire around your head like I mean
this neighborhood that you were in it
was this your neighborhood or no I was
Martin Luther King actually speaking
that was what yeah a couple days ago
yeah I already forgot the holiday 15
January 15th but the yeah the holiday
I'm just saying yeah I'm just bringing
it up yet sorry but you but you pick
this certain neighborhood to the hood
the hood
you picked the hood the hood because
black people give the best reactions and
it's nothing right I don't know if it's
came off races for some viewers or not
but no not at all I love black people
that's what I said on the news a lot of
black people did give the best reactions
they express themselves which I like
white people just like yeah get away
right people you want a reaction you get
a fool one now but then you were
deciding okay there's a bunch of
basketball players yeah I am going to
approach them as this zombie yes and at
that point the first time we do that
what do you think it I mean I was
thinking grade though I'm gonna have
1215 people running at the same time
he's got a feeling the one running
towards me you weren't afraid of that I
wasn't no I knew they're gonna run away
I thought I told you I felt so confident
once I did like three reactions that
everybody kept running so I didn't have
any doubt with something like this this
is gonna happen my friends like naw
they're adults and they were like over
like 20 probably and they ran I mean
there were guys climbing the fence over
the last reaction yes that I didn't see
that until I started editing that was
hopefully you didn't see the guy he was
on like the 20 foot fence
well after I edited yeah after I started
editing you
kind of down in a crouching position
yeah and one of the guy backfired minute
right the end of the video right so what
happened there there was like a clipping
or the guys running after you they ran
away cut you cut no no oh because the
video probably wouldn't go virally
fighting cut it it was just I told him
it's a prank and actually stopped and
they offered me crack yeah they offered
me crack they're like your party you
want some hard and hard is a crack on
the street so what'd you say I said no I
don't party I don't party like that Oh
funny I gotta go see our people on the
other side of the block I was like let
me is that cool if we use this for
YouTube video yeah yeah yeah you sure
you don't party so that I mean the guy
looks like they did turn on you and I
started chasing ya and you had a bad
moment that's like you're about to get
pounded yeah well he swung on me I heard
like I felt the air and then I turned
around he's about to swing at me again I
was like no no it's a prank yeah and
then he was like oh cool you want some
crack your party you want some crack you
want some rock your couch I was like no
I'm cool Wow so that's it so that's it I
mean that seems like that would not be a
typical reaction it seems like sometimes
you might say it's a prank and then
that's when they get mad yeah sometimes
they hate to be on camera like
embarrassed I guess right so what's the
worst thing that's ever happened a
russian hitmen 60-seconds prank I'll put
a suitcase next to some guy and I told
him in a Russian hitman outfit that's my
character fully suited Jon's favorite
character and then hair slicked back
Russian accent and i go to i go up to
people and go your life your choice you
have 60 seconds and I dropped a suitcase
and I run so they run but really don't
know the prank is there is money inside
the suitcase so 300 bucks and singles
and like you know laid out like it's a
drug deal whatever people think but yeah
and I had this one guy went off on me
really bad and he was black he was huge
and yeah he was he did he went Samuel
Jackson I mean he just sounded just like
him he started trying to beat me up now
right yeah it's on the video it's online
the sound kind of goes away and although
there was for that particular video
there was no sound so that's what I'm
going with the story there was no sound
so after we fought with the guy I didn't
really fight him but he tried to fight
he's like I'm gonna call the cops blah
blah so somebody called the cops because
they see me trying to beat us up so the
cops came and they arrested US for a
hoax bump
charge and then I told them like I tried
to fight it and said it's a hoax bomb
but there was no sound in the video and
I couldn't prove it so I had to wait a
year til I get off probation I got
charged and I got arrested and charged
arrested yeah I spent 45 days in jail so
what I mean what the charges got dropped
because I completed everything like it
said so what kind of opportunity for
pranks are there with 45 days in jail I
what do you mean like like are you like
in prank mode in jail or you know I
actually thought I was thinking a lot in
jail and I came up with some great
videos after I after I came out of jail
I started hitting a million views per
video because I just came up with so
many ideas that it worked
yeah I mean you're like literally in
jail writing down ideas for your next
prank video I don't write I'm done I
just remembered them in my head that's
how I do all my videos a lot of people
write them down I just know was there
that what are you in for a moment and
you were like YouTube yeah yeah just
yeah pretty much and everybody knew me
in jail because they see me on the news
getting arrested really yes it was does
that's a funny story because they I
guess they liked that I guess yeah they
respected you respect me pretty much so
yeah we're like I'm gonna make this my
own little workshop here in prison for
these 45 days and I'm gonna come out and
dominate YouTube pretty much yeah I
thought I had like hundred twenty
thousand subscribers at a time so I was
like whirring and stuff like that but
then everything was great
you were in prison or not in prison you
were in jail worried about your YouTube
momentum well I got yeah I woke a this
would happen I went to jail for ten days
I got out on bail and then I violated my
probation so I had I was already on
probation for something else and then I
can fake ID when I was 18 but it was in
Key West so I had to
weren't in Key West so I had to fly to
jail so flew to jail right when I got
the plane I went turn myself in but it's
a it wasn't experience I know I guess
now I'm better right what I do more
careful and you also put footage of your
yourself in court in the video that's
posted now right oh yeah that was a
great transition everybody loved it that
was it's avid made like it was like a
movie you were watching a movie pretty
much yeah well I mean it wasn't it was
footage it was news footage it was my
viewing core in court and then it's
transitioned to another how the anchors
were explaining about the prank for like
maybe five seconds and then the
transition like one year later after I
was on probation so I finished the last
I did the last clip for the ending to
like tell the story kind of in a prank
mode in the character and it came out
great right I mean it makes a better
story yeah better YouTube video you walk
right past the to sheriff car and then
you go up to a homeless guy yeah I
decided to do komuz guy because
everybody kept running for 60 seconds so
I switched the story up I was like in
Russian so you're telling me I wasn't
supposed to tell that 60 seconds the
whole time bla bla bla bla bla set in
jail because of you
and he's like no I just give him to him
the money then open the case and then I
open the suitcase and just gave it the
money to end the video were you worried
about potentially being caught just
doing that part of the prank now I slept
to the face I wasn't scared at all I had
a good lawyer a very good lawyer came
across a very good lawyer you were like
as long as I don't say 60 seconds yeah
I'm good and the mic is on this time
there's no bomb and then that was a
homeless guy it was a homeless guy yes
and he got 300 $300 is wasn't that yeah
he was he's pretty happy today yep he
says I'm leaving
he's like I'm done for today right yeah
yeah that's a pretty good couple of
minutes for him Wow I mean and at that
point after that video came out over the
next year is when you gained four
million subscribers over the course of a
year yeah I think yes last January I had
millions I had a million subscribers
last May
so less than a year yes Wow I had a
million subscribers like May 20th of
2013 so it's been what I mean eight
months and now you're over five - yeah
you're a fine man so I mean there's lots
of other people pulling pranks I want to
talk about that more later but is the
advice that you give to people who want
to pull pranks if you really want to
take off quick you should probably get
arrested for a prank and then it's
really gonna blow up
well like Snoop Dogg said in the
interview with him he says if you're not
get if you didn't get arrested you ain't
doing it right
like the prank or was he referring to
something yeah so just in general for
everybody whatever you do if we're not
arrested that's what you do you're not
doing it right
that's his life philosophy yeah
sometimes it works but I'm not also a
bad guy speaking of the extreme the
homeless guy I did extreme homeless
makeover you see that yes right yeah I
got the homeless guy need teeth and took
him shopping and all that's right and we
were staying I'm such an ass probably
that's my character right so that's kind
of what you that's what you said in in
the description of that video you know
everything I like it right so that
you're making all these videos where
you're kind of taking advantage people
getting their reactions or anything sure
jerk okay so you were like it's not
that's not who I am let me show you who
I am I'm glad actually it was a douche
II kind of feel like even the
description too is like let me show you
I am NOT just that I wanted to do a
homeless video always because I saw this
little pranksters doing like giving out
pizza and like Pocky change and like let
me do something creative and I just came
up with the extreme homeless makeover so
explain explain what happened extreme
homeless makeover I go out found found a
homeless guy named Martin he was
standing on the side of the road and he
said he was really hungry so I took him
to first to get new clothes got him a
hotel for two days haircut and then we
went to a steak house he ate a lot a lot
a lot a lot and then his biggest dream
was to get his teeth fixed so we raised
money on IndieGoGo twelve thousand
dollars and my goal was twenty five
hundred and indigo we didn't I want to
give me the money cuz they because I had
a criminal with the hoax bomb thing huh
so the end because he had criminal in
the past so didn't want to give us the
money so I made his public status that I
have to
turn all the money all the people
thought I stole the money and stuff like
that but they knew it after he returned
and I had doctors contact me and said
they want to fix his teeth for free so
you raised all the money you IndieGoGo
made you give it back to the people or
they never actually took it from the
people they never accepted the money
well they never expect on the site it
says the deadlines yeah it was like
twelve thousand dollars and then I just
get an email all the money was refunded
- right yeah so I didn't ever had in my
bank account or any latest yes pledge
but then they didn't they didn't
actually make any with I made a big deal
yeah and then see you all wanted to call
me and talk to me and apologize I was
like I don't want to hear you I don't
hear you speak nothing I was so pissed
but then a doctor didn't work doctor did
the work for free yes for some put some
credit I guess yes and this guy the oh
yes oh yeah Mon you said yeah Martin so
we did the video and then two months
late well I found out that his teeth is
gonna get fixed and so I go tell him
that the story and I had to move to LA I
was moving to LA because I was living in
Boca Raton so I told him I'm gonna be in
LA I'm gonna fly down when the doctor is
ready so I fly back down and yeah they
took his teeth out no they took his
sorry
they took his teeth out before I flew to
Los Angeles and then while I was in Los
Angeles I said his teeth he's wanted you
know healed his mouth your gums we're
ready to put the teeth in so he I want
to get to get the dentures the films and
stuff so basically I mean that was kind
of your reaction to that was your way of
saying okay I'm not that bad of a guy
that's my this is more the real me yeah
but I actually can be nice I just wanted
to make his day I guess I would say I'm
actually not nice now I just did the
videos I'm always come off as like a
douche bag and stuff but in real life I
always you know help the homeless people
always pass by and get money yes a
couple dollars here there right really
we feel bad when I know they're not yeah
when I've you know it was like why not I
mean this is something you wanted to do
why not yeah and I did just did part one
I didn't expect to - I was like I'm not
gonna hit fix his teeth there's no way
he's gonna make it possible and I just
took two months kind of just focused on
this video and I just made it happen
hello
well let's go back to just to learn more
about your background yeah where you
from where'd you grow up I was born in
Russia and raised in Ukraine Edessa I
guess a mama okay mom what's it like
having never been there are just third
world countries
say God has a lot of fun I know homeless
people huh
speaking of homeless people yeah a lot
of poor people I guess and not a lot of
people have the technology that USA have
Ryan wasn't your case with your family
yeah I was born uh I was raised with a
single mom and my dad was working here
so it was pretty tough for us that would
helped us out a little bit but what your
mom did what did my mom do she was some
secretary for a company I forgot I was a
little it was like 11 years old I didn't
really care I was living in one bedroom
and it was like literally one bedroom
you walk in and there's no like like the
living room is the bedroom so we had two
beds me and my mom slept it's pretty
poor and I growing up were in a poor
family and then my stepdad got an
opportunity to bring us here because he
got settled he said everything is
working out okay and so how did he start
working in the u.s. how did that he
started working in the US by moving here
and trying to do something and then he
started as a pizza delivery god and he
worked his way up to buy now obviously
it was I don't know when he moved what
year but he's a programmer now so yeah
but he was reading the books for dummies
that's how he got his degree he didn't
go to college he learned his programmer
job for the books for dummies that's a
good investment for that series that's
all you did is he read that and then he
went in an interview I mean if you can
get pet if you can be you know if you
have the humility to say I'm gonna read
a book that says it's for dummies then
I'm told it's really good
it was he's a smart guy but yeah but she
just read the books he was ironically I
got dummies don't actually read it
because they're dummies yeah exactly
that's a good point actually
but yeah so off the books and he won and
proved it that he can do it so what kind
of what kind of kid were you what were
you into bad kid
okay well in Ukraine we're talking to
Ukraine pretty back hit I guess always
sends to get in fights you know I always
grew up on the street pretty much you
know just running around with my friends
brothers and sisters okay only child
well yeah what kind of fights
I mean how rough does the school fight
you know Ukraine school fights we're
talking about switchblades no no no I
was 12 years old
you know silly fights in school always
was like a center of attention
what was your signature move did you
body shot punch people in the face or
not pull their hair dig not what body
should not face shot just a face shot
really you know it's funny because 12
years ago fights
most of the time it was related to link
what you know you mer the time I John
Carson was getting on you yeah I know
that I know that one time no and there
was a John ends or situation that was
related to you to John Carson was
picking on with this punched him in
probably third grade I don't know what
it was I always went for the body so you
guys go back then yes we were 6 5 6
years old but I would go for the body
shot which is unusual because I'm you
know I've got a good reach and I've got
the height yeah but I think I was just
worried about my hands but you knew how
to hold your fists
I guess who say so yeah well I always
did like boxer and karate when I was
growing up was my best friend so you
were like trained I was like sweet yeah
pretty much were you developing the
skill to not care if you were gonna piss
people off from young ages is that
something that you can see that you can
trace back that I don't care if I piss
you I wasn't yeah much if it's funny I'm
gonna do it well kind of thing no not
what no I think I just started doing
that for YouTube oh my god I never had
really thought about that before youtube
I was never really pissing people off I
was just funny I got class clown that's
what they called me but that's about it
so it's some more of the innocuous
pranks like some innocent pranks but you
might have punched some people in the
face so there's a little bit but never
together because there was people
started to fight first so I fought but
in America it's not the same but then I
came to America what age was that
I was 2004 so it was 12 years old okay
yes I mean that's a formative age to
make such a big move what was that like
in this was moving this is moving to
Florida it was moving to Florida with no
English at all new dog and cat I moved
to Florida and I went to Carver middle
school and I was the only white kid in
class
everyone was black because of ESL
because there's a lot of Haitians in
Florida so they couldn't speak English
neither so I was just there I didn't
have no friends
and I got in a couple fights with them
but then I learned the American school
system where you get suspended and you
get in trouble by your parents so I had
to stop doing the how did the language
how did you ever come that barrier I
mean my dad used to lock me in the room
and says you have to come out when you
learn all those words and it was
literally like that that's not gonna be
like I'm ready
did he like give you English for dummies
no no he did not Eva not evil he would
write I would write but he would write a
word in Russian and next to it in
English the one the ones I need to use
in school mostly so and that's how I did
it and then it just kind of went on so I
mean so how do you come in and not only
you're the only white kid but you're
Russian kid who's trying to learn
English again how was that first year it
was horrible it was crime not crying it
was like just like yeah I was like I was
crying at home and it was home like that
was because I had no friends I missed
all my friends in Ukraine Edessa
I don't know what I'm gonna do I'm never
gonna learn English I was freaking out
and then what changed or did it not was
the rest of the seventh grade was was
kind of bad but I went to eighth Kadena
I switched schools to eighth grade Don
Estridge middle school and then I took
computer class and it was kind of better
cuz I could play games in the computer
right but yeah I started learning
English more and started talking to
communicating with more people had some
friends and then yeah by the time I got
to high school I got better but I'm
graduated and it's good so when did
video-making enter the equation doesn't
11 okay so I would start videos for like
six months so I didn't take it seriously
because I was doing man physique like I
wanted to be
natural bodybuilder oh really I had like
6% body fat I was like eating like
measuring my calories well you know
let's say you were out of high school at
time yeah I graduated in 2010 so yeah
okay now I told myself I'm never going
to college I'm gonna make it without
college so okay yeah and you so you're
planning was the gym to be a bodybuilder
first yeah well that was a hobby that
wasn't my goal in life I'm like I don't
need to go to school so I can become a
bodybuilder no just did it just started
working out I saw great results I'm like
let me be one of those guys in the
magazine cover holding a protein shake
you know what I mean yes yeah that's how
it started and then my YouTube took off
and that's when I stopped I read in the
comments what was your first video I
mean you're you're saying okay I'm gonna
I'm lifting weights I'm getting swole is
that what she is that what you say yes
well I guess that's what you say yeah is
that what you said though I don't wanna
put words in your mouth no did I say
swallow back in the day I definitely
said do you even lift no I haven't
identified of that back then yet but uh
yes well look at myself flexing so what
was the first video you made and we're
you alone did you have friends you know
you got a camera were you editing
skateboarding videos I mean the Bang
Bros is that what you tried to make me
tell you know yeah but uh yeah Bing bros
back home I think I know he's talking
about what yeah let's not blow the
viewers you know you want to know you
viewers can a porn film I guess yeah you
would say so
okay that's your Freddie dart not in my
first I did skateboarding videos but
then my friend dragged me along on this
ride it was crazy I was 18 and dumb but
yeah almost bangbus and then I had to I
had to see uh I had to get a job from
the porn star while this random guy that
is supposed to penetrate her and then
yeah and then I had to it's getting ah
is his ex is gonna get X this is no you
know in it I fine yeah I did the money
shot on her face and I got paid yeah I
was imposed although all the people now
all the people know that I did that
because
slam big now so people found that and
they're like ah you couldn't get hard
you did couldn't this this this but did
he know that you know it was all screwy
she didn't say that they scripted but
whatever everybody knows porn is
scripted because it's bangbus like
supposed to pick you up on the side of
the street and stuff like a series gosh
I don't like cash cab but the cash yeah
the shots a little different yeah
usually to do differently usually they
have a they have a a pornstar guy
picking up random girls supposed to be
random girls but this time it's like it
was a pornstar take over it's supposed
to pick up amateur guys oh you were
playing the guy on the street yes got
you the boy next door I guess I see the
connection hottie builder you got a
friend you you know you got that was
before I started work you know oh yeah I
used to skate big-time then yeah we just
it happened I guess I turn 18 I'm like
what just I don't know I don't know why
not try porn I'm an adult now yeah I
don't know how I don't know how it's
happened I'm not saying I'm like my like
regret it's whatever it happened the
past I got to look for my future now but
it's like it's whatever right it nothing
but now it's out there it's what it's
the thing that you were like okay sure
I'm gonna do this nice paycheck to get
to do something I enjoy and then and
then all sudden you become this YouTube
star you know that people on the
internet are gonna find it do you
remember the day when you were like oh
people are finding this how am I going
to spend this whenever I uploaded
disturbing the peace part end that's the
day so yeah I don't know what that was
that and how did you find out that it
had been discovered super viral in the
comment section yeah it was great I was
like oh but then I was like whatever I
got over it
after a month those like whatever well
it's 2014 it's not 92 back in the day
when you like you know made a porno and
then you become a celebrity it's like
2014 you know like well it's also I mean
I think you think about what your you
know your videos and what you're known
for yeah it's not like you're making
children's you know
yeah I'm not working for Nickelodeon or
something yeah exactly my my content is
very vulgar and
yeah so now I'm known as a comedian I
guess on YouTube so you've just embraced
it and people look at that as a sex tape
yeah I mean we weren't even gonna ask
you about that no it's fine that's not
up because I'm not yeah I don't I don't
want to about it I don't have to I'm not
gonna hide it why should I
I'm an open person I can talk about
whatever that was kind of a one-and-done
kind of a thing for you too much yeah
did some extra shots some kind of wasn't
the business okay
they haven't found the other videos yet
okay no I was just filming I was filming
partially and then I got the opportunity
and then I was an extra and some some
parties and it was yeah I got a little
while but then it was dirty business it
kind of like a lot of people are doing
drugs and stuff and I'm not it was like
what the [ __ ] am i doing so I was like
let me let me do the YouTube thing
because I'm actually funny and it was so
the YouTube videos were kind of
happening in parallel with kind of
flirting with the the porn world kind of
a thing so I think so uh yeah
I don't know I mean let me think no no I
was right before my very first video or
maybe I think I did in and maybe like I
had two videos uploaded but it wasn't
much
those were skate videos to to pranks I'm
not sure I can't tell you exactly know I
remember now I haven't done any pranks
you know skate videos yeah okay so you
weren't thinking at the time you knew
you were a funny guy you were the class
clown so did you when you thought about
YouTube what was the strategy there were
you like okay I'm going to be a YouTube
star oh no I just started doing it for
fun not even know you can get paid and
you just write you were just like you
could skateboard yeah I can skate boy
and then I was like let me try something
new
let me try to like bring people I guess
and we're there other successful
pranksters out there before you did that
so you were okay I see this works I mean
I could do that I don't I'm not afraid I
mean I saw a lot of YouTube videos I'm
like what are these people get like
millions of views not on prank just
vlogs and like other stuff I'm like what
is this like what why can I get this
many views damn and I just started doing
it I got like a thousand views it was
really happy what was the what was the
first one you
during the piece part one it's just I'm
running around trying to kiss guys like
not literally I like on the cheek and I
like and funny right let me keys like
just being silly around the street see
how it go and the thing got like a
thousand views in like a while a
thousand people seen this video so I
kept doing it the views grew monthly I
guess yeah started getting like 10,000
views a video well when I start picking
up girls how to pick up girls part one I
did too serious is disturbing the peace
and how to pick up girls and then I went
to single praying so I'm like the
serious thing is not cool anymore enough
bar 10 that's where it ends and so how
long were you doing that before the
zombie prank video really popped um I
started and I started in August 2011
YouTube channel I did videos for six
months till this no I did videos at a
couple of videos and then I stopped
maybe in September until January I'm
like let me try this again because I
wasn't growing I had like 300
subscribers look god this is never gonna
work for me hmm
so I tried it again and I started
growing and then in May of 2013 no that
doesn't the attack happen yeah a 2012
Wow time flies yeah in May I shut the
video right genius and July was the the
one that arrested when I was like
YouTube is gonna be my job
and that's when it I mean at that point
you get out of jail and you're like
video video video I was like that's it
it's 120 thousand subscribers I mean
200,000 people are gonna watch me per
upload I've gotta do it right I mean so
you start feeling some pressure at that
point you know okay I pressure God like
it became an addiction right because you
let people who are watching yeah and if
I do this more people are gonna watch
I'm gonna keep doing this yeah if people
say I love it I love it like great
comments so I'm like why should I stop
and obviously did you do prank videos
you've got to get other people involved
you got to have people to run camera
having me how many just one camera go
this is just one person yeah
always it was always just well it was a
story before the zombie prank I had a
dis camera guy that was started a
YouTube channel with but I don't want to
get into that we got
hand control he pretty much he told me
he quit before the zombie long story
short he quit before the zombie prank I
said cool
bla bla bla zombie prank blew up all
where's my money he said you quit so
bubble I'm gonna sue you bla bla bla
boom you're not my friend anymore done
new camera guy had never had a problem
with him and then just one camera guy
and then I moved to LA getting higher in
a little production you know getting
high in the videos and you know trying
to get triple the views and right so
it's it's a little bit bigger of an
operation than it was when you are in
Florida yeah you got I'm just trying
more people yeah millions of millions
views per video now not a million and
I'm trying for 10 million each upload
right yeah and okay so that kind of
brings us to the the getting girls phone
numbers and kissing girls like making
out with girls that are total strangers
and all that type of thing
I mean I'm fascinated with kind of what
goes into being able to get into that
mode you know having talked about like
your pregame ritual and things like that
I don't I don't want to overreach by
trying to make a connection but being
like kind of dabbling in the whole point
industry and having the I would imagine
I've never done it I would imagine it
takes a certain amount of confidence to
be totally bare to be naked and having
sex with somebody or being at a you know
doing that and then maybe going to
pranks from there yeah doesn't even
require as much confidence I don't know
question yeah that's my question
that's which is which is do porn or
prank video parlor pranks cuz nobody is
not five guys or like four guys have to
watch you naked and supposed to
concentrate on because am I gonna go up
or what
right yeah I had to experience that but
yeah but so all sudden pranks you know
everyone's thinking wow I can't believe
he did that and you're thinking hey this
is easy yeah this is exactly I mean like
approaching girls who are total
strangers and then like a few seconds
later you're you're making out with or
they getting their phone number for the
camera yep
for the camera everyone thinks I get a
lot of girls in real life I really don't
care I mean I care obviously I like
girls but I don't go out like crazy for
the camera because I know the viewers
loved it the viewers think oh my god
this guy can talk to any girl but it's
all for the khatola show it's all for
the camera you know but if it's that
successful on your videos yeah that's
what I'm thinking is like I need to
build more confidence in my real life
without saying that when a camera is not
rolling you don't that's not your
approach
I do talk but not like I talk on camera
no we're not just like because I'm an
excuse I run my phone you've never tried
no I did my life I did a work a couple
times but yeah I did listen that that
one in particular to put your number in
my phone which was that Roman Atwood
that you partner with no Andrew hails
from LA okay yes sorry yeah now you did
that on the campus of BYU yes yeah it's
a secret nobody knows about it well
everybody knows it's BYU but there's a
secret to it I'm gonna tell you in a
second go ahead okay well let me let me
let me have your eyes yes we talked
about this I think that you were so
successful on that campus because of the
nature of of a Mormon girl just the
typical Mormon girl you really my
secrets
super super nice super super trusty ax
and so you kind of go up and you're in
there like this came this guy there's no
way this guy is that creep exactly you
know he's like my brother and I didn't
know that until my video I did the video
that I realized that this wouldn't work
anyway honest yeah we did like me and
Andrew Hales weren't like okay this is
only gonna work Abby wait no we just did
it because I visit him for a
collaboration so we did this and then
realized it's not gonna work in
California and this is not gonna work in
Florida and I test it it doesn't work
like working at BYU it was sure you try
heroes oh yeah I tried it didn't even
make something worth uploading it isn't
like a video worth upload well not undo
part twos so I wasn't doing for the
video I'm like in real life okay
you're just in real life you've tried
this technique yes
anecdotally in your own role I know
that's the or not yeah Miami they just
make out with you that was my next big
head what BYU they're not gonna just
make out with you
they actually I actually got two
reactions
UVU it's a campus over you yeah I got to
I kissed two girls in a row without
denials like and that's how I came up
with how to get girls to kiss you with a
three-question he worked the first two
girls I did - it worked I'm like this is
awesome
so like Andrew Hales does he's like nah
it's not gonna get a lot of use I'm like
are you kidding me you didn't believe me
you were doing let me get this straight
you were doing the put your phone number
in my phone prank and as part of that
you ended up kissing a couple of girls
no no no it was after it was a new idea
I was like let me because I uploaded it
while I was in Utah so you went big I'm
like people like getting numbers so what
do we do a step more why don't we kids
girls imagine that break the ice with
girls on the spot and I just did in
Miami my on my own but you did it okay
so you but you did in Utah a couple of
times yeah two times and it worked it
worked yes and then he didn't want to do
it with you
no I not not necessarily he did want to
do it actually yeah I kind of cuz he's
like he has a different audience he's
like Mormon people but it wasn't the
reason he said he wouldn't mind doing
two or three clips I just went to Miami
and keating really cared that I keep
that as an idea and I went to do it for
my million subscribers celebration but
that was gonna be an epic video and it
gets like 2 million views every month
still and uploaded a year ago now there
I mean there are a number of prank
videos out there now of guys kissing
girls like I saw Sam pepper thing yeah I
saw actually strewed a Stewart edge did
it he has been doing a lot he had he had
a magic trick yeah he does magic tricks
he does like some creative different
stuff like is pop kisses he doesn't make
how he just does a little right well Sam
didn't do that but Sam yes I really laid
out with the oils on Venice Beach yes
you did it first you were the originator
yes how kind of typing kids girls in
YouTube first videos me does that work
though because you obviously know all
these guys you work with them yeah and
if there's a sort of a prank video maker
Network is it sort of like hey dude I
got this idea I'm gonna kind of do the
kiss girls thing is that cool is there
like a phone call that takes place no
they do it because they do different
ideas like you know I did three
questions picking up girls like hey do
you have a boyfriend no do you think I'm
attractive yet what's your excuse not to
kiss me Sam peppers video was different
he was just interviewing girls he's like
I want to see how many girls that can
make out today and he would tell it to a
girl and she look okay let me make out
with you right you know it's a different
idea so I can't be like all it's mine
you know right he can go kiss girls if
he comes up with a different idea
he was certainly emulating you on that
one I think you guys are friends you've
collaborated well I met him after that
video I met him after yeah I met him at
VidCon last year did you talk about that
video
no I didn't I've never seen him before
do you was I thought he was a crazy fan
I didn't give him my number and then he
emailed me and was like put your phone
but you're never mother yeah pretty much
no this didn't work that way yeah it's
like I never seen him when YouTube was
like I don't know who he is I thought
you were just crazy fan so are you
trying to because there are those I
don't know five or so channels that are
really successful prank channels is it
like okay well now you want to be the
king of the YouTube pranks her you wish
those guys success how does that work
I wish everyone's success but I just
passed prank vs. prank so I'm the king
I'm number one prankster and youtuber
and now no cockiness and put a little
bow there yeah well so yes for a number
one as of pranks for now it's gonna stay
that way for now until if I start doing
script I don't like you know I'm over
the improv I'm not really over and pro
stuff I like scripting stuff you know
like I like people telling me what to do
like you know I want to start doing
scripts and stuff like have you know not
be an actor yeah yeah pretty much but I
want to do like to have a director tell
me what to do not saying scripting prank
videos like I want to do like films and
like you know tell people telling me
what to do like I want to be like II did
this wrong because I'm the director of
my own videos so I don't know if I do
good or not have you done anything that
on you on your channel are you are you
moving no I'm not gonna put that on my
channel no get all the audience yeah no
way I'm just gonna stick with pranks but
if I get something outside or pranks for
TV like this we're working on a prank
movie it's not really gonna be scripted
I don't know we're just writing it now
so we'll see well obviously if you're
writing it a script is so it's not kind
of like a jackass bad grandpa model tell
more crazier their pranks are like funny
but soft well jackass they hurt them
not really praying no there was some
pranks right yeah but grandpa it was
kind of it was hilarious
it was soft pranks but we're gonna do
like like are you gonna move leave the
movie theater and be like that you see
in jail for how many years
that's what kind of prank so that's how
we're gonna leave the audience more of a
shock yeah yeah pretty much like with
open mills watching the screen right I
think that's that's interesting
distinction we were talking about this
we're good friends with that bass master
who yeah it was awesome one of the early
mad I'm one of the early YouTube
pranksters and of course he takes a
different approach though because his
approach is very much he's gonna try to
play some comedic character he has
hilarious and he's gonna kind of push it
pretty far would you look at that look
at that you know until you kind of get a
funny reaction from somebody yeah you
take a different tack which is like I'm
gonna do something like you said were
you gonna question like is this guy in
jail and like what happened did that
Huckabee yeah after the camera went off
yeah exactly
so has that become the standard now like
we thought not when I started it that's
what was my point deal I was like I'm
gonna stand out I'm gonna push to the
edge every prank I'm not gonna be a soft
prank where they like get mad oh you're
on camera like when people get mad I
push it to the limit yeah that's what
makes you that's what makes me stand out
because there's a lot of you know a lot
of drama in my videos and so
logistically how does that work you've
got you mean once you make somebody in
that angry how do you get them to sign a
release form or how does that do verbal
releases okay I'm doing I'm doing a
prank right is that cool for you yeah
but when I was on probation they made me
do releases signing releases every once
in a while you blur somebody's face out
so because they say no to the permit a
nose yeah blurred the face if I get a
cool reaction now I dunno speaking of
that Bassmaster eat going back a few
years we just you know because we're
friends we were just ask him some
questions and he said I was like I
wasn't you know never had anybody get
really mad and he had some people you
know asked him to take videos down even
though they had given him permission
once I saw it yes so what's your
experience with that I had one video
taken down because I actually haven't I
did
you ask a girl for permission she went
off of me she beat me with the tennis
racket and I thought it was hilarious so
I blowed it and then her dad found out
and she's like she's getting bullied in
school because of you because you know
blah blah I didn't believe it I thought
it was just some crazy hater wanted me
to just take down the video and the
video disappeared so obviously the means
that YouTube verified the person so then
I believed that it was just something to
happen behind the scenes like they they
went through YouTube yeah they said I
can assume you know I'm not I wasn't
scared what happened what had at the
prank go down I was just I was just saw
being kind of trying to be kind of
flowers about how to pick up girls
series and my how to pick up girls
series is me like kind of talking crap
to girls but then make him laugh and
give me the number at then now instead
of being nice and this one was I was
assumed on a boat and I'm like I'm like
wow wow this is a nice cruise ship but
not as beautiful as your ass and I
switched the camera to her and I don't
zoom in on her ass I just kind of like
moved to the camera towards and she's
like excuse me what did you say and I'm
like you heard me
like with that camera Donnell's like
coming out putting that camera now
should I put that camera down I was like
I'm up and I wasn't gonna like you she
was nice
ask me nicely I would take put the
camera down but she came off so bad like
already
she put the camera down I was like no
she's like you want to I'm gonna hit you
in the balls I'm like it she's like in
three seconds I hit you in the balls I'm
like one two she gave you a countdown
yeah and I didn't know I gave myself a
car like okay you're not gonna hit music
one two three and then she didn't she
didn't hit me she's I keep wait I put
that camera down I was like alright fine
oh well I start walking away she's like
you better put that camera down and I'm
just holding it for you know for the
audio kind of up and I'm not pointing at
her at all and she just followed me and
then some lady with a husband screamed
the lady was screaming yeah break that
break they and the husband was like it's
freedom of speech is freedom but he's
allowed to do this and then she had baby
see and then I think it was a husband
I'm sorry maybe it was a some random
woman and another guy and then she came
up to the guy and she's like what you
say and she's like I'm about to knock
you out and the guys like oh if you
knock me hot I'll knock you out right
after and then and then I was like
like I said I said something vulgar
again to piss her off and at that point
I was like I don't give it I don't feel
bad for her she's a [ __ ]
so I'm like I said something I said it
saying I was I was like I like the way I
like I love your attitude I want you
it's just like bad yeah
yeah that's that I didn't have any
subscribers at that point so I did not
roll like now now would never do that
yeah but before I was like this you know
this is a YouTube video
let me laugh at this so she then she
goes dad across the beach I was like you
ain't got no dad and then she I was like
now go call your dad like a little girl
and that's what she started beating me
with the racket and we came on the
street the heart the car start honking
and she just back on the walk back on
the sidewalk and I walk with her friend
or she was with a friend and her friend
was so calm had a tennis racket the
little ones you know that you play on
the beach not but tell I got like a
badminton thing or something Bella does
the little rubber bought the wood add
the wooden yeah yeah like ping pong like
she was trying to paddle you yeah she
good the good explanation yeah she's she
paddled me on my elbow I think she
didn't hit my head she tried to I ducked
and they would have heard but yeah and
her friend was just standing there her
friend was so nice she was she didn't do
anything she was standing waiting for
her when she's gonna be done so she went
psycho on me
was that your worst beating no she just
barely hit what is your worst beating I
didn't have any beating except that the
black guy was stalking him a Russian
hitman he didn't really beat me he just
scared me because he looked like he
would kill me because he was so much
bigger than me and just screaming and
like spit coming out of his mouth I'm
like off I'm gonna die today my day you
were never I've never been punched in
the face No
as a result of a prank no well it seems
like that might need to be a goal though
more views you're right I mean I mean
they nobody just wants to punch me like
a one time I did a prank with Jack Vale
in my video and he actually got punched
instead of me so I'm like I just don't
get punched people don't wanna punch me
I don't know what it is I guess it's my
view beautiful blue eyes people feel bad
what do you say to the I mean we we dug
up the blogs online where people are
trying to analyze and point out that
you're fake and okay you you fake this
I've seen this person I love it I love
it
well the first older person multiple
videos that happened once and Olivia I
was filming in Deerfield Beach Florida
and I got a one reaction from a guy I
bloated a video and months later I did a
video and the world and there was a I
filmed a reaction again from the same
guy I didn't know he D know I'm like
you're on camera he's like wait I'm on
camera again wait Oh aren't you the same
guy and I have behind the scenes and
actually uploaded my second channel to
explain and then people are like what
are you doing that you're just showing
that you care about the haters bubble of
us yeah what the [ __ ] am i doing I don't
need to prove anybody anything so just
took it down on private and I just let
the haters hate then people still five
millions / 5 million people watch /
uploads cuz people want to pick it apart
people just just I guess I'm being the
bigger you get the more haters yet no
but I love it now I was like oh this is
great it means I'm doing something good
now ok so you you're saying okay people
haters gonna hate and I'm not gonna try
to go on and like publicly defend myself
do you think at the same time that part
of the purity of a prank video is making
sure that it's completely authentic I
mean is that is that something that you
say yeah I'm always going to make sure
that these people this is a legitimate
prank these people I haven't taught to
them ahead of time is that is that part
of your philosophy that's then what do
you mean part of mindful of the print
video this is gonna be a legitimate
prank I you know yeah haters gonna hate
but also at the same time it's kind of
well yet sometimes it's like like I'm
doing a real video you calling it fake
like some videos that aren't spend days
on doing it I don't care about some days
like I put hard work into the video and
people call it fake what I'm gonna do
but the dislikes and likes ratio is
always great I can barely see the
whatever it's not white or red it's
always green completely all the way so
that's what I don't care right um I say
it in the comments fake still it still
likes you know what I mean so that's why
don't you write like half a dislikes
half like something off this look as
hell right so I guess what I'm saying is
is you're not gonna you're not gonna
cater to the haters you're not gonna
spend time you're not gonna waste energy
on them but you're telling you're
telling us I'm this I'm not faking it
people are legitimate regardless what
people say yeah this is this is a
legitimate exactly these people are not
fake yeah there's always there's a
explanation this guy I'm in the same
town this guy shows up in my video
because I film in the same time what
happened once and then people started
saying and then after that people
started saying all the same people in my
videos and then when you go when they
compare the links it's like completely
different people they're just they're
just being trolls where you call them
Internet were keyboard warriors and then
what happened yeah and that's about it
you think there's something what I was
gonna say but I forgot let me see if I
can pop up what other other guys
some of these other guys out there who
are making prank videos you don't have
to mention any names that you think are
faking it no I just watched the stuff
that said I don't actually to be honest
I don't you watch I'm just like yeah I'm
I'm not gonna whatever I don't care if
it comes off I just click on it just to
see what they did so I don't do the same
idea and I click out of it I don't watch
so when you come up with an idea you
search and make sure it hasn't been done
exactly exactly so I'll go through my
pranksters all the pranksters on YouTube
I typed her name
check them and then I see the title the
videos look good I wasn't gonna do
something like that anyway it's just I
mean because you do collaborate yeah you
live people yeah yeah they collaborated
before yeah I just watch Roman Atwood
that's the only person to watch I'm not
gonna lie to y'all just go and I skip
through all your peoples video how rude
it sounds but I'm just don't watch prank
videos i watch them but just I just
watch just do research always something
a lot of times frankly you think you
think Roman Atwood in some of your in
your descriptions yeah sark a lot would
work a lot would Roman out with us we
were gonna be doing the movie with so
yeah Roman and dangerous so that's when
you guys collaborate on something
there's a mutual and maybe he has an
idea you have an idea like hey let's
make this happen together exactly yeah
okay we started working together I think
our first collabos with Tim yeah my
first collab was with him and then we
just click though it became more than
just partners we have friends I would
just started doing videos together so
going back to something at the top in
terms of when you're talking about
helping the homeless guy out and having
the image of being kind of a bad guy I
think you said
yeah II had to image of public image of
kind of acting douchey about this yes
people love people love me but there's
like people in select they love me like
oh but they think like you know I'm kind
you know do some people think I'm
douchey most of the people but they're
like they loved me I guess I don't know
it's hard to explain
you see awesome comments but people know
I'm like is this guy in real life like
that they don't understand this is
acting this is not really me in real
life so I'm nice I respect people but
you but so you kind of but you kind of
own and embrace the characters but I
mean your hat says villain it's not even
my head so I didn't know what that means
what does that mean villain my friend
gave me my is that really nice where I
don't know what that word means cookies
you know what that means
yeah I'm smoke weed all day every day
but not smoke weed sometimes it helps me
go to sleep but uh but but this is I can
tell you is this is yousef we see - we
see - he I my hair was the girl is
getting longer so I can't spike it up
and I didn't get a haircut yet I need
one so we went out to a club and he gave
me the hat and I kept it for now he %
villain hat I don't know what that means
I swear to god bill I was like that's
like the bad guy it's like the Joker is
the villain to Batman just awesome maybe
it suits me right I actually keep it
them yeah exactly
I'm just trying to figure out how much
okay owning and reveling and the being
the bad guy in your videos as a
character now it's all that kind of
bleeds in the real life versus how
concerned are you about about your
public perception of being but I am a
nice guy or I am NOT I mean you know I
mean what because I don't I didn't do us
crazy pranks anymore just starting to
you know slowly doing more pg-13 stuff
trying not to like I stop cursing tried
to stop critique you know how to try to
curse on my videos unless it's the
people's reactions and I don't bleep it
out because that's what I stand out my
channel stands out I don't bleep
anything it's like very rated and what
and what's the reason what why are you
taking the edge off in that way I
started like this and I thought it'd be
weird just to do it I don't know where I
think I tried it once on the video
people like started commenting what is
this what's happening TV Talia
everybody freaked out but
I knew if I kept doing it they would
have no choice and just watch it was
like why well I stand out other people
are bleep mine is you can actually hear
the curse words and if little kids
watching I'm sorry
they shouldn't watch them 18 and up so
what's uh what's the prank you got in
the works just to acknowledge I know
that you're saying you want to you want
to branch out and work on some other
things what get get into acting and
things like that you're working on the
movie but you're keeping your channel
going right absolutely my goal is like
you want to stay on top I just want to
stay on top and my goal is 10 million
subscribers by June so that's why I keep
doing it but yeah how are you gonna do
that you got some big pranks well I mean
I grow a million subscribers every month
so we got what five months left so June
6 so I'm expecting at least around you
just don't you just do a math at this
point yeah my math used to be my
favorite subject give us the scoop on a
prank you got in the works it's for me
to know for you to find out it come on
tell us man you were the woman to tell
you yeah it'll be it may be two weeks
before this comes out anyway so you
gotta go okay so yeah yeah well I just
tell him I guess yeah whatever nobody's
gonna film as good as I did so but John
came up with this idea actually we had
this girl go flirt with guys and then
the guys were really interested then
she's like let me see your hand your
hand looks kind of nice and soft and
they take the hand and she puts it on
her pants and on the pants she has a
fake dildo to the side and they think
it's a guy so they flip out and like
threatening her to knock her out and
stuff like that so another vulgar video
but have you shot it alright yeah we
shot it we shot it I supposed to edit it
and upload it but I didn't do that yet
do you edit I added all my videos
absolutely I don't trust anybody with my
videos I'll never let anybody ID it no
matter how big I get I'm if I'm gonna
squeeze in time oh now okay all right
why are you gonna get that and then a
couple years ago a couple years ago
no you you've got these aspirations
though you know if it's a TV show
obviously if some movie I'm not gonna
edit it but my YouTube video I'm gonna
edit it okay so and what's a prank
let's go beyond that what's a prank that
you haven't shot yet I wouldn't ever I'm
not gonna tell you
type of thing I'm not gonna steal it I
don't want people just listening I got a
lot of great ideas probably gonna run
out soon but that's why I got John to
help me my manager yeah he's been
pitching me some good ideas so how often
do you you film something and you're
like we can't this just didn't turn out
never happens every time I have an idea
I'm confident that this is gonna go in
the main channel so you've never
scrapped an idea this is a very good
crush I think maybe once if I did it
would be only once and I'm not even
lying like every time I go I'm always
uploaded everything on my main channel
like that I started doing pranks on my
second channel softer pranks and there
were in my extra footage there were just
me filming those in an hour too because
I just get simple reactions but the main
channel I'm only going for the greatest
reactions you know what I mean ten out
of ten every reaction to keep the people
entertained well I think that this is a
keeper
you mean this interaction yeah like just
like this has been a prank the whole
time have you guys been recording this
that would be quite a prank yeah to not
record until right now or if we did but
then tried to prank you and saying that
we didn't that would be actually a very
lame prank
we won't record oh just go okay there
you have it our conversation with Vitaly
we went to some places that I did not
anticipate going numb that was uh that
was quite a biscuit yeah yeah it was
there's different unexpected ingredients
in that biscuit you know an interesting
guy from from a different world than
ours you know with a very different
brand from ours so I think there's
certainly a fascination factor there
yeah you know I find it interesting that
he's obviously seen how pushing things
very far him he basically owns it he
understands that's what his brand is is
to push people to a point where they are
shocked and offended and angry on camera
and that's something that people like to
see at least to millions of views
he's basically hitting that number one
prankster spot on YouTube right now and
seems poised to maintain that spot on
YouTube and he knows that it's gonna
take more shocking and more offending
that's he said he's embraced that and
it's interesting because it's already
you know it's already resulted in a 45
day jail sentence right so where does it
go from here yeah yeah like yeah are we
gonna have Vitaly back on in in three
years and it's gonna be like he's gonna
be in a jumpsuit you know or we're gonna
be visiting him and he's gonna have on
the jumpsuit I just when when you - your
brand and that's how you set yourself up
and you're gonna keep pushing the limits
I'm just pathetic ly interested in where
that's gonna go yeah if you're breaking
limits what's the next limit and how
many limits are there you can you can
let us know what you think on Twitter
you know our handles also let Vitaly
know what you think of his ear biscuit
that's Vitaly ZD TV vit al y ZD TV to
let him know what you think
Wow yeah so here we are at the end
having learned some things how do you
feel I feel biscuit 'add well I'm just
but that's what I'm trying to come up
with something like some you've just
been biscuit it you've just been biscuit
'add you like that slate you should get
your Franco thing you should keep trying
I mean the word biscuit it kind of
doesn't it doesn't strike me in the
right way okay well you've just been
biscuit 'add I'm still I have nothing
better we do it every week and we
appreciate you listening and sharing the
love hash tag ear biscuits on Twitter
and everywhere else that you socialize
yourself in a media forum we'll be back
next week you please try to do the same
[Music]
[Music]